millones de pequineses han vuelto hoy a
trabajar después de las vacaciones si lo
hacen desde casa si se recomienda en
toda la ciudad pero es obligatorio para
los tres millones y medio de habitantes
del distrito céntrico de chayanne donde
también se han cerrado todas las
estaciones de metro en la ciudad se han
clausurado las escuelas los bares y los
restaurantes que ahora sólo pueden
servir comida a domicilio en el centro
es obligatorio hacerse una prueba pcr
diaria y mostrar el resultado negativo a
las puertas de los escasísimos espacios
públicos que quedan abiertos beijing
sigue extremando las precauciones para
controlar el brote que fue detectado
diez días atrás hasta ahora los tres
masivos no revelan más que una
cincuentena de casos diarios pero el
objetivo es que no alcance las
dimensiones del que obligó a cerrar
shanghai en más de un mes atrás desde
ahí llegan noticias preocupantes porque
se han vuelto a detectar contagios en la
comunidad después de que la semana
pasada subieran erradicados son apenas
34 pero bastan para alejar la
posibilidad de una apertura inminente
con la que sueñan millones de sanginés